14 million 605 different scenarios that
dr. strange saw in which the Avengers
only win one of them that's a point zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero seven
percent chance of them winning so not
very good odds
but fortunately right before Doctor
Strange turned to dust he pretty much
told Tony that everything happened the
way it was supposed to for that one
scenario to play out and of course
time-travel is involved so everybody is
saying that the Avengers can go back in
time and stop Thanos from getting all of
the stones they can unite and fight
Thanos together etc etc but what if they
actually can't go back in time and undo
anything that would definitely
complicate things a little bit but it
could definitely be something that we
see in Avengers 4 just the heads-up I'm
still doing my giveaway giving away
copies of Infinity Ward Deadpool 2 and
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray as well
as some special edition posters if you'd
like to enter for your chance to win all
you have to do is be a subscriber like
the video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so again time travel is pretty
tricky there's the whole butterfly
effect to way if you go back in time and
change an event it could severely change
in effect the future and like Doctor
Strange said everything kind of went
according to plan at the end of Avengers
infinity war this is why Doctor Strange
says there was no other way he's saying
that everything went according to plan
for that one scenario to play out to
where they win so here's where things
get really tricky in Avengers floor with
time travel and that one scenario where
they win if the Avengers go back in time
and change something and they change the
future
then they are no longer in that one
scenario that Doctor Strange saw them
winning there are certain events all
throughout time in the MCU that had to
happen in order for everyone to end up
where they are now and in this one
scenario if you go back in time and
change some events then you will change
the future that can have some serious
effects for the Avengers for example say
Tony goes back in time and he prevents
all that happened in Civil War from
happening so there is no civil war there
is no fight between him and Captain but
if there is no Civil War
then there is no Black Panther and
there's no spider-man and if Black
Panther isn't in the picture then
neither is what Conda and neither is
Black Panthers army and that was
obviously a huge force to fight against
Thanos as outriders and if you listen to
dr. Strange's words very carefully he
says I went forward in time forward in
time not backwards in time this sort of
solidifies the fact that everything that
has happened had to have happened I
think Tony will realize this as they
start to explore time travel I think
they may even go back in time and change
something then go back to the present
time and realize that it had a huge
effect on the future so then they'll
have to go back in time again to undo
what they just did I think this is
probably where the alternate realities
come in they can't affect their own
realities timeline but they can go to an
alternate reality and collect Infinity
stones from there and bring them back so
with this probably comes a big sacrifice
from Tony with time travel you can
essentially do anything you want you can
prevent something from happening or you
can make something happen yourself and a
man like Tony Stark would probably have
a lot of things that he'd like to change
but most particularly his parents dying
with time-travel Tony will have the
ability to save his parents but again
preventing that from happening could
change the future severely he might not
even become Iron Man if he prevents his
parents from dying but that's a choice
that Tony is going to seriously have to
consider we learned in civil war that
Tony actually believes that all of the
villains that have come to earth are
because of the Avengers the avengers
being on earth and being as strong as
they are basically invites villains to
come and try to take them on so tony in
his mind would also have an opportunity
to prevent all of the chaos that's
happened over the past 10 years from
happening so this is a choice that
Tony's going to have to make he's going
to have to choose to not save his
parents so he can stick to that one
scenario that dr. strange saw where they
win he'll have the power to save them
but won't be able to because once again
Ironman has to save the world
so his ultimate sacrifice and Avengers 4
could very well be his parents but let
me know what you all think about this
theory you think that this will be
Tony's biggest sacrifice or do you think
that he's going to have to sacrifice
something or someone else let me know
your thoughts in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers 4 thank
you all so much for watching woof woof
[Music]